but I got to ask you because of Y
combinator because of startups and so on
the recent
and you've tweeted about this uh about
the Silicon Valley Bank svb what's your
best understanding of what happened what
is interesting what is interesting to
understand about what happened in svb I
think they just like horribly mismanaged
buying
while chasing returns in a very silly
world of zero percent interest rates
um
buying very long dated instruments
secured by very short-term and variable
deposits
and this was obviously dumb
I think
totally the fault of the management team
although I'm not sure what the
Regulators were thinking either
and
is an example of where I think
you see the dangers of incentive
misalignment
because
as the FED kept raising
I assume that the incentives on people
working at svb to not
sell at a loss they're you know super
safe bonds which were now down 20 or
whatever
um or you know down less than that but
then kept going down
uh
you know that's like a classy example of
incentive misalignment
now I suspect they're not the only Bank
in a bad position here
the response of the federal government I
think took much longer than it should
have but by Sunday afternoon I was glad
they had done what they've done
we'll see what happens next
so how do you avoid depositors from
doubting their Bank what I think needs
would be good to do right now is just a
and this requires statutory change but
it it may be a full guarantee of
deposits maybe a much much higher than
250k but you really don't want
depositors
having to doubt
the security of their deposits and this
thing that a lot of people on Twitter
were saying is like well it's their
fault they should have been like you
know reading the the balance sheet and
the the risk audit of the bank like do
we really want people to have to do that
I would argue no
thank you
what impact has it had on startups that
you see well there was a weekend of
Terror for sure
and now I think even though it was only
10 days ago it feels like forever and
people have forgotten about it but it
kind of reveals the fragility of our
economics we may not be done that may
have been like the gun showing falling
off the nightstand in the first scene of
the movie or whatever it could be like
other banks for sure there could be
well even with FDX I mean I'm just
uh was that's fraud but there's
mismanagement
and you wonder how stable our economic
system is
especially with new entrants with AGI I
think
one of the many lessons to take away
from this svb thing is how much
how fast and how much the world changes
and how little I think our experts
leaders Business Leaders Regulators
whatever understand it so the
the speed with which the svb bank run
happened
because of Twitter because of mobile
banking apps whatever so different than
the 2008 collapse where we didn't have
those things really
and
I don't think the kind of the people in
power realize how much the field had
shifted and I think that is a very tiny
preview of the shifts that AGI will
bring
what gives you hope in that shift from
an economic perspective ah because it
sounds scary the instability I no I I am
nervous about the speed with with this
changes and the speed with which our
institutions can adapt
um
which is part of why we want to start
deploying these systems really early why
they're really weak so that people have
as much time as possible to do this I
think it's really scary to like have
nothing nothing and then drop a super
powerful AGI all at once on the world
I don't think people should want that to
happen but what gives me hope is like I
think the less zero the more positive
sum the world gets the better and the
the upside of the vision here just how
much better life can be
I think that's gonna like unite a lot of
us and even if it doesn't it's just
gonna make it all feel more positive
some